les faits se sont déroulés après midi au
robert à 14 heures selon nos sources une
grosse dispute aurait éclaté une
policière de la compagnie départementale
d'intervention âgé d'une quarantaine
d'années et son conjoint de 30 ans pour
des raisons qui restent à déterminer
il semblerait qu'il a eu de nombreux
échanges de coups entre les deux
protagonistes au domicile de la
policière durant cette interrogation
l'homme se serait réfugiée dans les
toilettes la fonctionnaire dans un
mouvement de colère
où est alors utilisé son arme de service
elle doit tirer à travers cette porte
alerté par les détonations les voisins
préviennent aussitôt les gendarmes
l'homme fort heureusement ne sera pas
blessé
interpellé la policière placées en garde
à vue pour tentative d'homicide
volontaire
quelles sont les véritables raisons qui
auraient poussé cette femme en service
depuis une quinzaine d'années à agir de
la sorte
seulement que diligentée par le parquet
et confiée à l'inspection générale de la
police nationale igpn déterminera les
causes précises de cet acte signalons
que cette fonctionnaire bénéficie pour
le moment de la présomption d'innocence